[Music]
[Applause]
the only rule is to rule the field
introducing the latest sport taking the
mushroom kingdom by storm
strike
mario strikers battle league football
strike is like football if football had
an electric fence no rules and intense
5v5 battles
sure you still dribble pass and shoot
for the goal
but with no fouls you can tackle thrash
and even stop your opponents in their
boots with items the controls are simple
so get a team together and let the games
begin but first here are some battle
tested striker strategies
[Music]
a team that tackles together scores
together
push a teammate for a team tackle that
covers extra ground for defense or
scoring
[Music]
get hands on and push your team to
victory literally
[Music]
another strat for star strikers is the
hyper strike
first get your gloves on a strike orb
when it appears on the pitch
charge it up
and let it rip
each character's hyper strike has a
different flourish and can score two
points by showing that net who's in
charge
[Music]
get rough pull off hyper strikes and
work together with your team to win
you'll have 10 total players on the
field with each character having their
own signature striker style
need a jack of all trades mario's your
man want to punish with power bowser's
the bomb need to score and shove with
speed that's peach's prowess
the rules may be
non-existent but protection is paramount
luckily some stat changing gear can be
equipped on characters heads body arms
and legs
boost speed for superior dribbling
up your strength to resist tackles
or up your shooting power for more
scoring potential
combine characters and gear to create
your superstar soccer squad
a total of eight yes eight players can
shoot their shot on the same console
even using a single joy-con controller
per player
you and another brave contender can get
together on the same console and show
your striker synergy online show no
mercy when playing against friends
family or rivals near and far
friendship can be forged amidst the
flames of strike like in the online only
striker's club mode where your own club
competes against others for rankings and
promotions
create your own club or join an existing
one
up to 20 strikers can join a club
[Music]
in striker's club you and your fearsome
friends play matches to accumulate
points each season
these points determine your club's
ranking so keep an eye on them
these matches can be played alongside
others in your club or you can strike
solo for points
your ranking at the end of each season
determines which division you'll compete
in during the next season
compete ruthlessly to earn points get
promoted and become the top club you can
also get demoted so the stakes are high
aside from an official sounding title
club owners also get to manage members
and customize kits best of all as club
owner you can give some flair to your
lair by customizing the club stadium
with different goals and pitch designs
two club stadiums will smash together in
striker's club matches to form a single
stadium
get gritty with mario and friends in
strike
where anything goes
mario strikers battle league football
available june 10th only on the nintendo
switch console